[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] ويسعدني أن أعلن أن لدينا الآن
اتفاقًا يمهد الطريق
لفنلندا والسويد للانضمام إلى الناتو تركيا
فنلندا والسويد ، وقد
وقعنا مذكرة تعالج
مخاوف تركيا ،
أجرينا
مناقشات مستفيضة للغاية وفي  في نهاية
ما يقرب من أربع ساعات
يمكننا الاتفاق على أننا سنرى غدًا
اجتماع
دول الناتو
الأخرى ونتوقع أن نحصل
على بيانهم حيث
تتم دعوة فنلندا السويد
إلى الأعضاء ليصبحوا أعضاء
، وبعد ذلك سنبدأ في الوصول إلى
المفاوضات
حيث تسمح فنلندا والسويد بالدخول
إلى المفاوضات بشكل كامل.  دعم تركيا ضد
التهديدات لأمنها القومي ، ويشمل ذلك
إجراء المزيد من التعديلات على تشريعاتها المحلية من خلال اتخاذ
إجراءات صارمة ضد أنشطة حزب العمال الكردستاني
والدخول في
اتفاقية مع تركيا بشأن معرض
[موسيقى]